no oh no oh don't worry Adam I'll save
you filthy Tom Lawler Royce Isaacs was
having trouble with my watch buddy he'll
be right there Lawler a former MMA
fighter he looks like it turn pro
wrestler and MGF showing no sense of
urgency here here I come Adam I'm Gonna
Save the Day as Lawler and Royce Isaacs
go MGF he's gonna save his partner
in New Japan strong enough to tear it
apart if an MGF has to put his scarf
down it's an expensive scarf look at
just a two-on-one beatdown
look at these two guys look at the the
terrified of them yeah team filthy oh
man I almost had him running for the
hills darn I would I would fish close
Chicago